We all have this negative self talk that
goes in our head.
Guess what?
There's enough people that are telling
us we can't do it,
that we're not good enough.
Why do we want to tell ourselves that we
know for a fact that thoughts influence
actions?
We sat there with the,
um,
with the video sheldon,
Dr Levy,
so right.
We know that our thoughts influence
actions.
Why do we want to see that negative self
talk to ourselves?
We need to get our own self affirmation,
Muhammad Ali.
What was his self affirmation?
I am the greatest.
Who else is going to tell you they need
to be quiet moments in your bedroom,
quiet moments when you're brushing your
teeth,
that we need to reaffirm I am the
captain of my ship and the master of my
fate.
That is my affirmation and looking
forward to a time that I would feel good
again,
helped me to keep moving forward.
And sometimes I had to be brave and it
wasn't always easy.
Sometimes I faltered,
I had bad days,
but I realized that being brave isn't
supposed to be easy.
And for me,
I feel it's the key way to keep moving
forward.
So all at all,
I don't waste energy feeling bad for
myself.
I surround myself,
people that I want to be with,
and I keep moving.
So with this philosophy,
I hope that all of you,
regardless of your obstacles,
you can have a very happy life as well.
When I am the captain of my ship,
I don't see it.
If no one else will
get away,
there's enough of that Muhammad Ali,
I am the greatest.
There is no one better than me.
It's a difference between Hubris and ego
and false pride.
It's just reminding yourself and quiet
silent moments.
I put it down on the list.
It's right beside my mirror
in
Russia.
Ever mainland Japan ever met in your
pyramid in America,
the whole world.
Big Deal.
So I kept working to
be champion of the world,
but better than all of those before me,
I'm not going to argue with you.
You're going to be just like that in
some of your already there.
Well,
you don't know how you're going to make
this happen,
but you just feel within yourself some
way somehow with the help of God,
I'm going to make it happen.
Repeat after me please.
No matter how bad it is.
Oh,
how bad it gets.
I'm going to make it.
I'm going to make it
shakes his hand on your right and left
and say you got the right stuff.
Yes,
it's possible for you to live your dream
because it's not about where you come
from.
It's about hormones.
That's number one.
What's number two?
Number two,
test number two.
I want to make sure you got it.
This has to be
the important thing.
Is this like what I'm saying?
Listen,
to me,
the most important thing is this.
To be able
to sacrifice what you for.
I have wrestled with alligators
out of handcuffs,
lightning and in jail.
Last week I'm murdered.
Angelo's stone hospitalize a brick.
I'm so mean.
I make medicine sick,
dude,
man.
Fast,
fast.
Cut The light off in my bedroom.
It switched.
Was in the band for the room was dog
fast.
You George Foreman.
All you chumps about.
When I up in all of you,
I know you get him.
I know you got him picked,
but the in trouble.
I'm going to show you how great I am.